[Musique]
les enfants donc la dictée d'aujourd'hui
va commencer le titre la visite des
paquebots la visite des paquebots à la
ligne plusieurs fois dans l'année
plusieurs fois dans l'année
virgule pape a emmené pape a emmené sa
petite famille visiter pape a emmené sa
petite famille visiter un des grands
paquebots un des grand paquebot des
messageries maritimes
un des grands paquebots des messageries
maritimes points c'était pour nous
c'était pour nous la grande sortie du
dimanche la grande sortie du dimanche
virgule un peu comme lorsqu'on allait un
peu comme lorsqu'on allait
dans la famille un peu comme lorsqu'on
allait dans la famille pour un grand
événement pour un grand événement point
d'exclamation à la ligne nous étions un
peu frustré nous étions un peu frustré à
chaque fois qu'on assistait à chaque
fois qu'on assistait
au départ d'un navire au départ d'un
navire points fin de la dictée pour les
cm1 à la ligne
un navire qui emportait un navire qui
emportait des familles entières
des familles entières pour de longues
vacances en france pour de longues
vacances en france point
les voyageurs agitaient des petits
mouchoirs les voyageurs agitaient des
petits mouchoirs et et nous leur
répondions part nous leur répondions par
de grands signes de la main de grands
signes de la main révélant malgré tout
révélant malgré tout notre joie
d'assister au départ notre joie
d'assister au départ
ouais
tout cela me faisait rêver
tout cela me faisait rêver points face
de la dictée pour les cm2 à la ligne
mais ce qui me faisait rêver le plus
virgule 7
la vie à bord
c'était la vie à bord d'un de ces géants
des mers
la vie à bord d'un de ces géants des
mers pendant près deux mois pendant près
d'un mois
et et les nombreuses escales du voyage
les nombreuses escales du voyage au nom
au nom de l'étrange de l'étrange et de
l'ailleurs et de lier points de
suspension
il y avait surtout il y avait surtout
[Musique]
cette magie des noms de lieux
cette magie des noms de lieux qui
agissait déjà sur moi cette magie des
noms de lieux qui agissait déjà sur moi
pire gül poètes des ports en quelque
sorte poètes des bords en quelque sorte
qu'ils se disaient qu'ils se disaient
deux points j'irai là bas
j'irai là bas
point d'exclamation fin de la dictée
pour les sixièmes à la ligne les noms de
ces géants des mers les noms de ces
géants des mers qui desservait la
réunion depuis marseille je reprends le
début de la france écoutez bien les noms
de ces géants des mers qui desservait la
réunion depuis marseille virgule avait
une particularité remarquable
avait une particularité remarquable
virgules il commençait tous
il commençait tous par la lettre elle
point à la ligne
une visite de paquebots une visite de
paquebot était pour nous promesse de
cadeaux
une visite de gbagbo était pour nous
promesse de cadeaux points c'est un
l'unique occasion de boire une orangeade
c'était l'unique occasion de boire une
orangeade virgule nous qui étions aux
habitués à nous qui étions habitués à la
seule limonade de la boutique la seule
limonade de la boutique points
fin de la dictée pour les cinquièmes à
la ligne il y avait aussi le coiffeur à
bord il y avait aussi le coiffeur à bord
y recule toujours aussi élégant toujours
aussi élégant virgule qui nous offrait à
chaque fois qui nous offrait à chaque
fois la cordiale hospitalité de son
salon la cordiale hospitalité de son
salon point d'exclamation
maman avait droit alors à sa coiffure de
l'année maman avait droit alors à sa
coiffure de l'année points le salon de
ressembler à une chambre de petits
sultan le salon ressembler à une chambre
de petits sultan point à la ligne
il y avait ça et là il y avait ça et là
bien gül par terre par terre gül des
poufs des bouffes bien qu'une quantité
de dagues et d'épée quantité de da2 et
d'épée virgule petit chameau petit
chameau et chevaux de bois et chevaux de
bois ou encore sur les étagères ou
encore sur les étagères virgule toutes
sortes de statuettes toutes sortes de
statuettes 1,2 cassolette de cassolette
virgule de bijoux multicolores de bijoux
multicolores points
fin de la dictée pour les quatrièmes à
la ligne un jour un jour virgule notre
coiffeur remis à papa notre coiffeur
remis à papa un joli bronze de néfertiti
pouvant servir de presse papier un joli
bronze de néfertiti pouvant servir de
presse papier et et qui trônent
aujourd'hui encore et qui trônent
aujourd'hui encore sur un rayon de ma
bibliothèque sur un rayon de ma
bibliothèque points
la pause coiffeur épuisé la pause
coiffeur épuisé virgules
nous continuons la visite du paquebot
qui nous continuons la visite du
paquebot qui au fur et à mesure au fur
et à mesure prenait des allures de
grande tour eiffel des allures de grande
tour eiffel vient nul de châteaux de la
loire de châteaux de la loire virgule à
nos yeux des colliers empli de la seule
histoire de france
à nos yeux des colliers empli de la
seule histoire de france point
d'exclamation fin de la diviser vous
voulez écrire le nom de l'auteur patrice
c'est d'après patrice trop tard patrice
trop tard je vais appeler pelé son nom t
majuscule route-66 d'été alors vous avez
encore quelques quelques petites minutes
pour bien vérifier une dernière fois
qu'ils aillent aux que n'oublie sur vos
copies
[Musique]